hi everyone today I'm here with two
friends James who you would have seen
before and my office mate Qi so they
both know quite a bit about quantum
mechanics actually and that's going to
be the topic of this video so for James
his PhD is in a quantum mechanics area
you know and you want to say it's
experimental based quantum mechanics
specifically in quantum communication
and information yep and she like tutors
of course in quantum mechanics and might
have a bit of perspective there you're
also a PhD student you want to say one
sentence about what your work is I work
with silicon and I'm trying to make it
absorb infrared alright so this video
was inspired by a few quotes that we've
all seen regarding the possibility I
guess of understanding quantum mechanics
so one of the quotes I know is from
Richard Fineman and it was that he said
it's safe to say that nobody understands
quantum mechanics so I forgot to ask you
guys what you think of that well in some
respects I would say it's true people
don't understand the reason why quantize
particles act the way they do way
basically particles act as a wave and a
particle however I would also say that
any actual quantum physicist understands
the mathematics behind how the particles
act so in a sense they do understand
quantum mechanics they just don't
understand why it's quantum mechanics
mm-hmm do you think it's possible to
understand kondo beginnings yeah it
depends how you define understand but if
you just think about if you understand
quantum mechanics in a mathematical way
and accept that at that level
everything is quantum mechanical and it
behaves differently from the microscopic
world then yes you can definitely
understand quantum mechanics but if you
want to understand why at that level
things like tunneling and quantum
mechanic evening can happen then
no definitely nobody's going against ya
like the quantum mechanics that someone
would learn and say
undergrad is that just a mathematical
abstraction of quantum mechanics that
like a version of quantum mechanics that
is easy to understand do you think I
would say that in general in undergrad I
think they start with the maths just
because it's just easier to start with
the mass and I think in Java at least
for me I think I started with doing the
mass and just mechanically doing all the
operators and stuff and learning how to
solve shorting I think white equation in
some sort of potential but then I never
really physically understood what was
happening I guess in third year or in
spots or fourth year I started to really
try to understand it physically but fail
um but do you think you've got somewhere
to like a physical understanding more
physical than before yes but no we're
not like physically understand why an
electron beam hits them yeah yeah no I
like I agree that I think the physical
understanding is quite difficult but I
think I've heard this quote used as sort
of a misconception from students who are
like well maybe they did bad on a
quantum mechanics test and they're like
oh that's fine
no one understands quantum mechanics
anyway but that's sort of taking it out
of context know what that quote means it
doesn't mean you can't understand the
max which is probably what you were
asked to do on the test it means there
we have this mathematical description
you can learn this and you can do well
at this regardless of that physical
intuition behind it yes yeah insurance
shouldn't be discouraged by that court
thinking that I'll never understand
quantum mechanics because nobody would
ever understand quantum mechanics that's
not what the court means the court means
learn the maps be confused and
eventually you understand why you were
confused that's what yeah of course to
correctly because to extend on that when
you're first starting with quantum
mechanics it's an actual quantum system
is very confusing there's a lot of
particles interacting with each other
and slightly shifting the way that the
system behaves so when you're first
starting off it's easy to take one
particle put
a simple box and say how does this work
how did the energy level structures
behave and such and even in the
simplified case it can still be
confusing to understand why physically
yeah yes just different
yeah but then once you've built up that
understanding you could take it to say
actually looking at an atom with energy
levels and you can say okay the energy
levels behave like this and the sort of
structure this is similar to the box
there's just a lot more factors you need
to take into account because it was
another version of this quote we were
talking about earlier yeah John Wheeler
was that don't you have that one there
John Wheeler and I believe I have the
code up here still it is if you're not
completely confused by quantum mechanics
you do not understand it mm-hmm yes I
guess we're saying it's it's sort of
natural to be confused by the physical
intuition but allow yourself to be
confused allow yourself to just
completely not understand what's going
on immerse yourself in it and eventually
you may find some understanding in the
fact is it's kind of an indication that
you are thinking in the right direction
you're actually actively trying to
understand and failing just as everybody
does instead of just accepting the match
and not thinking of it very much and
you're thinking that you understand when
you haven't actually thought about it
because it does make sense to be
confused because up until this point you
would have been doing say low-level
thermodynamics mechanics and things that
take place in the macroscopic world
where you can throw a ball watch it fly
and you can say okay that makes it
parabola this makes sense to me
then when you get down to the quantum
world I don't really like that quote but
sure once we get down into the very
small scales
you can't imagine say throwing an
electron at a wall and watching it
tunnel through the wall that doesn't
make sense to you because you don't live
in that sort of realm that doesn't
happen on a day-to-day basis you need to
get your head around this new world with
new rules basically yeah I think it's
hard to understand things that we don't
see a lot of physical intuition is based
on what we see and know we words are
there in that scale the intuition will
be very different in whatever we see
like a ball going through a pair
our trajectory will be counterintuitive
I guess that's what we don't live in
that scale so yeah do you think you'd
have any advice for like undergrad
students in quantum other than just to
stick with it and like try to get that
physical understanding like how did I
get to that point I'll just say you'll
get there eventually as long as you try
don't give up
definitely don't give up and don't
accept that it's something that you
can't understand just try your best to
understand it and you'll eventually see
that there's really nothing to
understand thank you dear Court I think
it makes perfect sense yeah hmm what do
you do any advice from you yeah stick
with it
basically allow yourself to I would
actually know I'd say you have to fight
against the idea that you have to try
and visualize what's going on don't try
and visualize putting a particle in a
box and seeing what happens just allow
yourself to understand the basic idea
maybe try and read up on some actual
real-world examples but they are going
to be quite confusing and possibly over
your head if you're not on the sort of
third year or beyond university level
even in third year or fourth year you'll
be continuously bombarded with new
quantum ideas yeah that you would just
not understand and in you go through the
same process again just with a more
complicated problem and more not
necessarily more accountable to it but
still as confusing in an idea to make
you feel incredibly uncomfortable yeah
and when you're reading on this still
just to understand the system they'll
throw a whole bunch of mathematics at
you a whole bunch of matrices and
symbols that are really quite confusing
and daunting when you first look at it
and it takes a long time to sort of just
read through that and you start to
understand what these matrices mean and
what having non diagonal elements in a
matrix means and what the diagonal
elements do to the system yeah I guess
don't be afraid to feel uncomfortable
with it which seems to go with a lot of
learning to people yes yeah a lot of
learning because they
yeah all right thanks guys yeah all
right